President Trump is turning his attention
to guns just days after calling for new
restrictions on e-cigarettes the
president is spending the weekend at the
White House considering an even more
contentious issue his administration
could be ready to release some type of
gun control proposal as soon as next
week Ben Tracy is at the White House Ben
good morning good morning the White
House has been talking to both
Republicans and Democrats on Capitol
Hill trying to figure out what if
anything they can all agree to the
president wants to be seen as taking
some issued some action on guns rather
in the wake of all these recent mass
shootings but a moment at this week's
democratic debate may have once again
changed the dynamics I met the mother of
a 15 year old girl who was shot by an
ar-15 former Texas congressman Bedwell
Roark had perhaps the most memorable
line of this week's Democratic
presidential debate hell yes we're gonna
take your ar-15 your ak-47
but now some of his fellow Democrats
fear O'Rourke's words will be used
against their efforts to pass new gun
control legislation I frankly think that
that clip will be played for years
at Second Amendment rallies with
organizations that try to scare people
by saying Democrats are coming for your
guns or Rourke has made gun control the
centerpiece of his campaign since
back-to-back mass shootings in his
hometown of El Paso and Dayton Ohio last
month the background checks and various
things having to do with guns
president Trump met with his top
advisors Thursday to figure out what
measures the president would actually
support most likely focusing on mental
health and expediting the death penalty
for mass shooters after the recent mass
shootings mr. Trump had said this but
after several calls with the National
Rifle Association the president backed
down but we already have very serious
background checks we have strong
background check and Thursday mr. Trump
seemed more focused on protecting Second
Amendment rights from what he views as
overzealous Democrats Democrats want to
confiscate guns from law-abiding
Americans so they're totally defenseless
when somebody walks into the house with
a gun it's like whatever you want
whatever you want I'm defenseless
whatever you want how crazy is this now
it's worth noting that this week the
president called for a ban on flavored
cigarettes in part because they have
been blamed for the deaths of six people
but so far this year nearly 10,000
Americans have been killed by guns Jeff
thank you very much